Every decision we ever make
soon come chaos
chaos soon come
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
venom let there be carnage video kevin feige was
also recently doing a really big interview
talking about crossing venom over into the mcu
like canonizing venom to the mcu so i'll explain
what he said because it's actually pretty cool
a lot of it has to do with what they just did on
the loki's series so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a bunch of really cool stuff coming up and
i know everybody's asking about the spider-man
no way home trailer i will talk about that too
because everything that marvel and sony are doing
behind the scenes with their spider-man and venom
movies is connected right now but in the venom let
there be carnage trailer there's a whole bunch of
spider-man movie references specific to the toby
maguire spider-man movies and we've known for a
couple years now since marvel and sony renewed
their sharing deal for the marvel mcu spider-man
movies with tom holland that they would eventually
be doing a crossover movie between spider-man and
venom but right up until kevin feige did this
brand new interview there hadn't really been
any talk about how they would handle all the
venom stuff in the newer sony spider-man movie
characters inside the actual mcu when that new
deal got signed a couple years ago kevin feige
just previously commented that spider-man would
be traveling between universes sort of tipping his
hat to what would be happening with the multiverse
that we just saw play out in the loki series
but spider-man would also be traveling between
cinematic universes meaning their plan was to have
tom hall and spider-man show up and event a movie
that sony was making on their side of things like
it would not be a big mcu production the way the
tom holland spider-man movies are in when he was
explaining spider-man hopping cinematic universes
he really didn't mention the words venom morbius
or anything like that implying that he didn't have
any immediate plans to canonize venom to the mcu
or any of those other characters by having them
show up in a marvel made movie with tom holland
spider-man but all that talk was happening before
they had started filming no way home before we
learned about any of the spider-verse multiverse
elements and before the loki series completely
upended the mcu multiverse like we saw in the
loki finale so i should also say careful for
spoilers from the loki finale i'm assuming most of
you have seen it by now but recently in the past
week kevin feige was doing press for the loki's
series in the upcoming marvel phase 4 movies and
did this unusually long interview where he talked
about literally everything in the future the mcu
including spider-man and venom i cut this down a
little bit just to make it a little bit shorter
but this is him talking about spider-man
no way home and then venom in the mcu
we got to make two great spider-man movies with
amy pascal and john watts and tom rothman and
tom holland and i was very proud of that and very
happy at that of course wanted it to continue
luckily tom rothman and bob iger and alan
horn and alan bergman and tom holland himself
all realized would it just be more fun if we just
kept doing it let's not let let's not get business
or politics in the way because the deal always
started with amy pascal and i having nothing to do
with numbers or contracts or politics it had to do
with story and a love of of spider-man and peter
parker and the marvel universe and it effectively
has continued like that and that's and that's
where we find ourselves now michael morbius
got tired of doing the whole good guy thing
what's up doc as it relates to any characters that
marvel studios hasn't hasn't brought to the screen
yet having been in marvel for 20 years i wouldn't
dismiss anything i wouldn't rule anything out
when and how and where remains to be seen
it could it could be you know any rumor that
you read online could happen uh any time between
tomorrow and never if you wonder what's going on
with the hat that he's wearing during that that's
a hawkeye hat just to tease the hawkeye series
that's going to be like the next big marvel disney
plus live action series after the marvel what if
series is coming up you can usually guess what
project he's working on based on the hat that he's
currently wearing the fun thing about listening to
him talk about all that stuff is that he's trying
to be this verbal ninja and not give away mega
spoilers for their exact plans for handling venom
inside the mcu when they start crossing spider-man
over between movies but there's also a much
longer clip with him talking about the sam raimi
spider-man movies and what's going on with him
working on doctor strange multiverse of madness
it's not completely relevant for what's happening
between spider-man and venom but it is cool to
listen to him talk about sam raimi coming full
circle kevin feige also was an executive working
on those original sam raimi spider-man movies so
that's what he means when he says things have come
full circle to say nothing of all those rumors of
the tobey maguire and andrew garfield cameo scenes
and no way home but also a little while ago there
was a larger interview about spider-man venom
sinister six big movie plans that a top-level sony
executive did a little while after the last big
venom let there be carnage trailer was released
the way he talked about it spider-man no
way home in the mcu would explain a lot of
people's questions for how the future of the sony
spider-man movies in the mcu spider-man movies
would all start blending together with all the
sinister six movies even with the venom characters
so it sounds like right now with the current
crop of movies that we have like venom let
there be carnage andy serkis the director
explained that during the movie there are a
lot of very obvious spider-man references like the
biggest in the trailer that we've seen or the dla
bugle newspaper that patrick mulligan is reading
eddie brock reading the daily bugle website is
not just that we're getting the daily bugle
which is a cool easter egg for j jonah jameson
it sounds like there's going to be another cameo
from him during the movie but it's also the same
daily bugle logo from the tobey maguire spider-man
movies this character patrick mulligan is also the
host of the toxin symbiote in the comics there's
the scene of cletus cassidy smashing the spider
when he's using his own blood to write the notes
to eddie those are the notes that you see him
reading at the beginning of the trailer with the
venom symbiote cooking him breakfast making that
huge mess but after that last big trailer came
out andy circus said and i don't think that he's
lying or anything that during the events of
the movie at least the main part of the movie
all these characters venom carnage mulligan are
not aware of the existence of a spider-man now
he didn't say that spider-man doesn't exist
inside the universe where the venom movies
are taking place because morbius is a direct
spin-off of venom and there's a very notable
spider-man costume inside the morbius trailer so
clearly there's a spider-man inside this universe
now it's the tobey maguire spider-man costume that
they're using here but there's a lot of reasons
why they could be using that particular costume
we also have michael keaton's vulture the same
vulture from spider-man homecoming showing up
during that movie then that same sony executive
who was talking about how spider-man no way
home is going to completely answer how all
this crazy multiverse stuff is going to work and
how they're going to cross these characters over
also said that venom let there be carnage was
going to be so good you would not miss spider-man
so along with what andy circus said it sounds
like just right now tom holland will not show up
in venom two in a big way they'll just have lots
of spider-man references and easter eggs then in
the morbius movie there's a little bit more legit
blending of spider-man references from the mcu
then when we get to spiderman no way home
then they'll use a lot of these big twists
from the loki finale with the craziness of this
multiverse kang war that's happening to explain
how all these different characters from all these
disparate franchises of spider-man movies are
coming together and that also tangentially will
eventually include the venom character just not
so much in spider-man no way home think about it
this way kang's all-out multiverse war that he was
explaining the loki finale during the war as all
the kang variants were battling each other they
were trying to destroy all the other variants
universes there was a rumor that the title
spider-man no way home was a reference to the
spider-man villains that show up during that like
doctor octopus from the toby maguire spider-man
movies electro from the amazing spider-man andrew
garfield movies they're stuck on earth and they
have no way home that makes a little more sense
as the universes that they came from have been
deleted they literally cannot go home but just for
reference as far as i know kang is not supposed to
be a big character during spiderman no way home or
during doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
issues that they're in the middle of the kang
multiverse war when these movies are playing
out so at least for right now it just sounds
like their plan is to use those tears in reality
across the multiverse universe is being deleted to
allow sony spiderman characters to cross over into
the mcu and that will eventually include the venom
character at some point the way kevin feige talks
about it though they don't have a timeline for
that yet they just know that at some point they'll
probably allow that to happen but loose plan right
now it sounds like the actual spider-man venom
crossover movie will be something that sony does
after the next venom movie in after spider-man
no way home and when that happens they'll also
have some small way of canonizing venom to the mcu
but it sounds like bare minimum that movie would
be like two three years away so hopefully that
explains a little bit about their loose plan to
capitalize on all the chaos with this multiverse
war that happened on loki but everyone let me know
in the comments how do you think they're going
to use what happened on loki to explain all the
sony spider-man characters crossing over into
the mcu in as far as the spider-man no way home
trailer it sounds like sony plans on releasing
that sometime before the end of the summer
so sometime in the next couple of months of course
i will do all the spider-man trailer videos the
minute they release that i will be doing videos
for marvel's what if series those episodes are
going to start in a couple weeks so make sure you
have alerts enabled so you don't miss any of those
everyone click here for my brand new loki season
2 teaser and all those kang deleted scenes and
click here for that first look at all the brand
new spider-man suits in spider-man no way home
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!